In Somalia, ten people are dead after a suicide attack targets officials...
...at a hotel in Mogadishu.
In the Philippines, one person was killed and two others wounded...
...in a shootout inside a fast food restaurant.
Two passenger trains in Switzerland collide, injuring five people, one seriously...
...and disrupting routes into Zurich.
In Venezuela, government officials arrest opposition Caracas mayor Antonio Ledezma...
...on suspicion of planning a coup to overthrow the Venezuelan president.
And finally from Ukraine, Kiev residents paid tribute Thursday...
...to the people who lost their lives during the Maidan Square uprising a year ago.